I am seeing the transparent finale glow
seeing it no how are we feeling excited
it's like dancing and singing shouldn't
just be what we all do all the time so
what do you hope the legacy of
transparent will be in this finale hmm
who wants to start
don't you have to okay we got to be part
of a movement for trans people around
liberation and the fact that the
conversation got started I guess five
years ago when the show start was it six
years ago seven years yeah not too long
ago when you think about it that the
world has changed so quickly we love the
fact that we were part of it and there
at Ground Zero when it happened and then
the musical is our opportunity to I
think say goodbye but also transition
into a new form which is the musical
form and have this joyful way of dealing
with the pain of the loss of Moreh but
also reminding ourselves that life is
about finding joy yeah and you guys have
been through a lot as I mean just
collectively the joy of being part of a
hit series and then obvious trauma did
all of this bring you guys closer
together huh it's insane working like
having it and just like a family
there was a there there's when there's
an earthquake there's a you know there
was a little of like I don't even know
how to walk now and there's just been
this we've actually had like two years I
think of healing and getting back and
bringing in new family members and and
yeah figuring out our way and now in
that weird way when you have gone
through something really intense you are
definitely closer you have reaffirmed
your love and connection in a way that's
much
deeper ya know the level of intimacy has
really has weavin folded ourselves into
each other not to the exclusion of
anything or anyone else and one of the
things that I think is most potent and
that jill has spoken to is that when the
show is making its own transition and to
have a character when a character can no
longer speak there are no more words
it's just experiential they must sing
and then even further they must dance
and that is literally what has happened
here and we also had we sat with each
other in many different places and many
different experiences where we sat and
talked out our feelings we were all
transparent no pun intended with each
other in order to move through something
you can't stay in one in stasis without
expression it will it will crush you and
Jill led us there and invited us all in
this incredibly safe and powerful way to
speak what our truth was yeah I love
that and also the idea of making this
musical where'd this come from
Shekinah and I were talking because I
blank faith yes people and she is music
that is the gay one first
[Laughter]
actually we've been collaborating since
we were little too so it's and they did
a very big hit show musical adaptation
of something they don't know yeah from
Chicago yes yes yes and I remember when
these guys were doing I was doing a play
called cannibal cheerleaders on and so
I'm they were doing Prison [ __ ]
there was an actress called prison [ __ ]
that couldn't do it so they kind of had
to get in they said McKnight here and
granny anoints theater called me and
said Alex can you come in and step in
for Susan Messing Susan Messing
because she's leaving and I said why
can't cuz I'm doing Kendall chillers on
crack and they said well Carolyn rose on
crack starts later you can do gifs were
known by Chicago theater for decades and
this is no surprise this is
you know musicals are the utmost of
collaboration tabes for it's true it's
such a team sport yeah and we have a
queer choreographer who's not mentioned
right now Ryan Ryan hasn't and a music
producer and Previn but everybody like
and this one's a singer yeah yeah but he
kind of brought in their hidden skills
or wannabe skills and Shekinah has been
working in theater in New York forever
and I'm Shekinah
so was there anyone that was nervous
about doing a musical singing acting
cool everyone was like the whole time
how we do it and then Jill says I'm
gonna push you up you're gonna do it I
catch you I don't get and hear you and
here you go and just before you go
here's your parachute yeah that's how it
works the safety of the space
yes is what is so sacred yeah would you
say this finale is a fitting end to all
this I don't think it's a nanny I mean
maybe it's an end to this incarnation
yes version this way that people are
used to experiencing the pfefferman
families but I mean the ferments have a
lot more to sing about yeah it feels
like a new beginning actually actually
it does and we've all talked about that
the day there's a last number in the
musical when I don't know if you've seen
it yet when you see see and we were all
talking on that day when we shot that we
all said oh oh this is the beginning
this isn't the end and everybody feels
that I'm so glad you address that
there's a great quote by Gertrude Stein
who says the end of something is always
the beginning of something else oh yeah
and that's what this feels like yeah
yeah are you guys gonna party after this
like what are the plans our party we're
just gonna ride your lights coattails to
every drop every award show invites are
going to every party
I mean for Judith Light
Canada let's go this is what your
children are doing for you yeah they're
so wonderful than most wonderful
children anyone if you don't give her
the Emmy I'll break your face oh we
curse especially gosh she's
congratulations to you also by the way
married life
[Applause]
hey Jewish television lovers sarahfey
Furman married Josh Lyman you know what
someone wrote on my Instagram I love
that a meal and Decker married James
Corden I met mr. Whitford on this show
and I always say to Jill you gave me the
greatest creative experience of my life
and the great love of my life I don't
know well you guys are a joy to talk to
the finale was great and I just think
that you guys are just so much fun I
want to see the evolution of this group
what's next I'm excited to see it what
are you gonna save one thing which we've
sort of said but I want to just go
straight to it yeah I was able to reach
into my pocket and pull up my secret
solloway weapon ooh this one oh I can't
sibling my whole life who I knew was a
musical genius and to be able to have
her come running up like somebody just
beat me up on the playground and say I
got you and for me to go faith I love
all your music and your talent let's
let's let's show the world how talented
you are it's about this family it's
about this family it's about love it's
about healing and it's about our whole
transparent fan family so we can't wait
to bring everybody in and heal together
like I had like a tear for me it's two
years because yeah yeah that was one is
so beautiful but that's the trip that
the response that you're having is the
transparent experience we've always said
you don't watch transparent you feel
trans and this is what that comes from
you you feel it and it doesn't matter if
the content of your family is that you
have a parent that transitions what what
you what what's Universal about this
show is that it is a family and
everybody has an experience in their
family of somebody who says I'm not the
person you thought I was
this is who I actually am and the
question to them is the question that
Joe posed to us at the very beginning
which was will you still love me if I
tell you who I really am
I just got a message literally yesterday
on Instagram from a girl who is about 13
years old who said she's turning 13
she said I'm from a country that doesn't
allow me to be trans hmm
so she dresses up in secret so her
parents don't know and this is a country
where it's not only shunned it's illegal
so it's dangerous for her so she has no
other outlet yeah and I helped return
her right you it was in super him and
she wrote me and she said I don't expect
you to answer this right so I answered
her immediately and said thank you for
your bravery thank you for your courage
thank you for your kindness thank you
for your you know do what you need to do
in order to stay safe but be true to who
you are and listen to your inner self
yeah because that's the truth the stuff
you're learning and the stuff you're
hearing are the lies that would not be
possible without the creation of this
show of this portal and with these
humans at the helm I feel as Judith said
a sense of safety but also it's opened
up a dialogue internationally that never
would have occurred so it's not just
about seeing the television show
it's about as Judah said experiencing
the message of artistic freedom and the
sense of the human experience through a
true life force their parent actually
went through this and that in and of
itself among anything any awards any
accolades any reviews anybody that's
watching or isn't watching it's really
the foundation of what this television
show is for is the human experience yeah
well I always like to end with
[Laughter]
take us home